OUR HEAD WRITER, ROBIN THEDE.
HER NEW SHOW "ANOTHER PERIOD"
PREMIERS ON COMEDY CENTRAL
JUNE 23rd, COMEDIAN ACTRESS
NATASHA LEGGERO
AND RAPPER AND ACTIVIST
MICHAEL RENDER AKA KILLER MIKE.
OKAY.
EARLIER IN THE SHOW WE TALKED
ABOUT RACHEL DOLEZAL.
A WHITE WOMEN UNDER FIRE FOR
PRETENDING TO BE BLACK.
OKAY, I HAVE TO ASK YOU.
WHAT DO YOU THINK WAS GOING
THROUGH HER MIND.
ROBIN, EXPLAIN TO ME.
>> THINK WHAT WAS GOING THROUGH
HER MIND.
I WANT TO BE BLACK.
I HATE MY FAMILY. BEING BLACK
LOOKS COOL.
>> Larry: YOU THINK THERE WAS A
HATRED THING THERE?
>> HER FAMILY?
>> YES.
>> FOR SURE.
HER FAMILY OUTED HER.
>> ALL WHITE KIDS HATE THEIR
FAMILIES.
>> DO THEY HATE THEM THAT MUCH?
>> HER PARENTS HATED HER TOO.
Larry: THERE ARE DEFINITELY
ISSUES THERE.
>> THEY SHOWED UP IN THE WHITE
SHAW, WHITE SHAW.
THEY DIDN'T CLAIM CHEROKEE INDAN
OR ANYTHING.
WE ARE WHITE.
WE ARE GERMAN.
I AM GERMAN.
>> LET'S SEE -- WOULDN'T YOU
RATHER BE BLACK THAN GERMAN?
[LAUGHING]
>> OH --
Larry: I THINK IT DEPENDS ON
THE TIME PERIOD.
[LAUGHING]
>> 2015.
Larry: I DON'T LIKE HOW
BLACK IS THE BAD THING.
LIKE, YOU KNOW I'M REBELLING AND
I'M GOING TO BE A BAD THING
CALLED BLACK.
>> WHAT IS INTERESTING ENOUGH I
WAS IN GERMANY LAST YEAR.
WE HAD A DRIVER WHO WAS
OBVIOUSLY A MIXED KID ME.  AND
MY WIFE.
>> Larry: MIXED WITH GERMAN --
>> AFRICAN AND GERMAN.
CURLY HAIR, WIDE NOSE.
BEAUTIFUL BROTHER.
ME AND MY WIFE WERE ABOUT TO GO.
I SAID I HAVE TO ASK YOU WHICH
ONE OF YOUR PARENTS IS BLACK.
HE SAID HOW DO YOU KNOW.
MY SAID SAID BECAUSE WE [BEEP]
LOOKED AT YOU.
I WAS LIKE YOU DON'T -- SO OTHER
PLACES I GUESS IT'S EASIER.
THEY DON'T FOCUS ON THAT THE WAY
WE DO THIS THIS COUNTRY.
>> HERE IS THE PROBLEM IN THIS
COUNTRY.
MY FATHER IS GERMAN.
MY MOTHER IS BLACK.
NOW EVERYONE IS LOOKING AT ME.
BLOND HAIR, GREEN EYES.
ARE YOU BLACK? AND I'M LIKE,
LAST WEEK YOU KNEW I WAS BLACK
DO I NEED TO CARRY A PICTURE OF
MY MOTHER AROUND?
>> YOU'RE THE LEVEL OF BLACK
THAT RACHEL IS TRYING TO BE.
[LAUGHING]
>> SO TRUE.
Larry: IT'S PROBABLY --
PROBABLY A DIAL WHERE
SHE IS LIKE OKAY, BLACK ENOUGH.
OBVIOUSLY SHE DID THINK ABOUT
THAT, NATASHIA, RIGHT.
WHERE DID THAT TAN COME FROM?
IS THAT SOMETHING ON HER SKIN.
>> THE MALL.
THAT'S A MALL TAN.
I LIVE IN A WHITE SUBURB AND I
SEE 50-YEAR-OLD MOMS IN TRUE
RELIGION JEANS AND THEY'RE ALL
JUST BASKETBALL ORANGE.
>> IT'S KNOWN AS LEVEL THREE
MYSTIK TAN.
YOU HAVE TO EXFOLIATE GREAT.
>> I WANT TO KNOW WHAT WIG SHOP
IN SPOKANE WASHINGTON SHE GETS
HER WIGS FROM.
>> Larry: LET ME ASK YOU, IF WE
TALK ABOUT THIS, IF SHE'S DOING
GOOD THINGS FOR THE GROUP ARE WE
MAD AT HER.
>> I COULDN'T BE MAD AT HER
UNTIL I FOUND OUT SHE WAS IN
SPOKANE.
NOTHING HAPPENING IN SPOKANE.
THEY HAVE TO IMPORT THE
BLACK PEOPLE FOR NAACP THERE.
>> Larry: SHE HAD TO GO TO
CANADA FOR THE MEETINGS
GOING TO VANCOUVER.
[LAUGHING]
>> TRY.
SHE GAVE QUICK ANSWERS.
ARE YOU AFRICAN-AMERICAN?
WELL I DON'T CONSIDER MYSELF
AFRICAN AMERICAN.
I CONSIDER MYSELF BLACK.
BLACK PEOPLE HAVE GIVEN WHITE
PEOPLE A LOT OF PASSES.
BILL CLINTON, COLONEL SANDERS
AND TIGER WOODS A SUPER PASS.
>> SHE DID GROP UP 4 BLACK
SIBLINGS AND HER PARENTS
SEEM MEAN. THEY'RE LIKE "WE JUST
LOVE TELLING THE TRUTH AND
WE HATE OUR DAUGHTER."
THEY CAME OUT AND SAID THAT
ABOUT HER.
THAT WAS HORRIFYING.
>> Larry: PUNISHMENT: YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE BLACK SIBLINGS
>> LARRY, I FEEL A HUNDRED
PERCENT SURE OF THE NUMBER ONE
HALLOWEEN COSTUME IS
GONNA BE THIS YEAR
>> Larry: HER?
>> YES.
>> TRUE.
>> WE WON'T BE INVITED TO ANY OF
THOSE PARTIES.
>> Larry: LET ME ASK YOU THIS.
SHE SAYS SHE IDENTIFIES AS
BLACK.
IS BLACK JUST A THING NOW? A LOT
OF YOUNG PEOPLE
HAVE EQUATED HIP HOP CULTURE
WITH BLACK.
THEY SAY HIP HOP CULTURE IS
BLACK.
>> NOT ALL BLACK PEOPLE SAY IT'S
OUR CULTURE.
>> Larry: IT'S PART OF OUR
CULTURE.
IT'S NOT LIKE MARTIN LUTHER KING
SAID YO, YO, YO, I GOT A DREAM
[BEEP].
HE WAS BLACK.
THOSE GERMAN SHEPHERDS KNEW HE
WAS BLACK.
[AUDIENCE GROANS]
WHAT, IS IT TOO SOON?
IT'S JUST ANOTHER GERMAN
REFERENCE.
MAYBE SHE'S BLACKISH.
MAYBE SHE CAN SAY THAT.
WHAT ARE WE THINKING.
WHAT IS BLACK.
WHEN YOU HEAR BLACK.
WHAT DO YOU THINK, NATASHIA?
WHAT DO YOU GO TO FIRST, COLOR?
>> IT SEEMS OUTDATED.
Larry: THE TERM.
>> YA.
Larry: MAYBE CHOCOLATE IS
BETTER.
>> NO, I MEAN WHAT DO I THINK
OF?
I KNOW SO MANY DIFFERENT TYPES
OF BLACK PEOPLE.
>> Larry: ARE YOU GETTING
UNCOMFORTABLE NOW.
>> KIND OF.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU.
I JUST GOT MY DNA TEST, AND I AM
6%
SUB SAHARA AFRICAN AFRICA AND I
HAVE BEEN BRAGGING ABOUT IT
SINCE